deux grosses explosions je trouve pour
la suite de huntingdon il nous reste
trois essais pilotes je pense que là on
va savoir qui est le tueur je l'espère
en tout cas mais avant précédemment dans
un match il date c'est bizarre mais oui
ce m
non et riche le choix appartient
merci on a besoin d'un décès vous plaît
[ __ ]
la soie
m
c'est parti chapitre cette violence à un
hôpital et où un peu trop cache quoi ah
oui c'est vrai que sam devait se faire
kidnapper s'était fait kidnapper par
dont la cre qu'est ce qu'il fout là mike
hague
il a réussi à s'enfuir de l'asie les
risques à la maison écrit ça je ne sais
pas ce qu'il en est il y avait ici au
dessus de l'espace qui leur est arrivé
au final iphone va y arriver
tell me brûle quoi tu fais une brûlure
indienne mais un peu hardcore quoi étape
du dessus de brûlures à dien bien
violente alors à ça j'adore ça ça fait
vachement pervers peu comme si tout va
bien ça va toi on est curieux on est
choqué tais toi qu'est ce qui t'arrive
et lettres pour blaguer
ah bah non tri vos compromissions 2 et
une porte là elle s'ouvre pas tu peux
lui offrir de ton côté jouy
j'y vais de ce pas mike ou non je
croyais a rien de pire quand tu te fais
chassé par un psychopathe que quatre
anciens va être pas juste puisque
régulièrement ça m'arrive alors avec sa
hotte total réduit ses dégage et ça
dégage parfait bombe ait n'a pas réussi
à pêcher au jesse ce qui va se passer
avec sam domoni orient vient on n'y
vient pas bon on va tomber sur haché
crise non
à l'ailé de zombies j'avais déjà trop
bien faire il y avait un très léger
c'est quoi ça entends-tu le parler des
balles à blanc
oh non sérieusement c'est du bla bla bla
l'heure
je vais
elle n'est pas morte non [ __ ] trop
d'infos pour la promo cerveau explose à
les minorer y arriver allez on y va elle
et pose un peu artistique je trouve non
aux pauvres au testament les tonga ont
la pacha et mini n'est pas morte mais
elle est dans les mines ou mad mats
effet débuté par une sorte de zombie le
hall à la bouche rouge de la bouche de
là tout va tomber sur toi je regarde ça
ça va aller dans ton corps un ton anus
alors bouge vraiment visible
ces trente centimètres ont sauvé ta vie
[ __ ] du coup elle est blessé on va se
faire poursuivre oui dans la main vous
avez entendu 600 $ dans le vent jusqu'à
ça vaut le coup j'étais super bien
second souffle ou s'en fout adore la
mode celle des vêtements de quoi elle a
l'idée de pour d'un bâton mais d'un
autre côté du bâton trempé dans des eaux
qu'elle a fait koh lanta parfait à l'oni
bas je suis saint léolin j'oublie le
trac
alors on se met dans le wagon et sa part
en space mountain mon gars comme on de
danse party bon dedans
non tous ces morts tu as bien fait elle
emilie allait les prends l'élévateur
retourne à la surface alors vas voir une
énigme à la con je le sens non voilà ça
marche pas photo un générateur une
bêtise du genre voilà poil et là haut
ils font exprès de montrer où il va on y
va
alors comment moncla au bal à la tout
simplement je viens tu brilles et on y
va
non non c'est ce qu'on a vu au tout
début du jeu quand anna et les bêtes
étaient dans la forêt au le métier là
quoi le mec est là ce mec n'a pas de vie
[ __ ] sans déconner tu veux pas jouer à
hawaï aux stones à battle fichiers pas
faire tu de ta vie bordel il va nous
défoncer être un couple en eau la bâche
a prague des liqueurs celui-là c'est
vous dire à quel point c'est tout
non mais si c'est inquiète pas inquiète
pas y'a rien au nom il y en a partout
des squelettes mon gars
en fait c'est tout les gens qui sont
tombés dans le trou comme au début un
diabète si tout ça aux mecs
j'arrête les blacks je m'excuse plus
tard soit pas violent y'a pas mates
matin matt échec et mat pour matt et ben
c'est gros c'est quoi se gratter grimper
grimper allait aller aux [ __ ] akuiteo
opt en buvant du thé oméga plus de
respect pour le cul tu es tu t'en sors
très bien et minutes sort très bien
souhaité aller soit jusqu à l aube là
hop là voilà on attend les châles à
gbagbo font avec les seychelles des bars
allez cette fois à l'échelle ska pas
quoi sans déconner à au monde en a marre
on va tomber nez à nez avec le cadavre
de maths
non c'est bon on avance dans la pénombre
[ __ ] ça sent le souffre ouais je le
flair c'est quoi ça du réseau non
al'inverse plein verse de toujours
espérer
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça bordel je
veux savoir qui ce mec [ __ ] c'est pas
josh lui c'est un mec qui crachent du
feu hisse en tête pour le cirque
ok on est là où il y avait le générateur
on est encore gardée voilà yade
générateur allez on active c'est parti
hopla parfait
parfait mais bien ouais exactement
direction là s'en sort pour retourner à
la surface pour l'apache
attendez on dirait le gooding jr des
anneaux c'est là y'a une grosse pelle
araignée une dizaine araignée géante
qu'est en train de bouffer frodon ça me
fait penser à cela
voilà c'est hyper intéressant vraiment
on est épanoui dans cette vidéo
ok mais arrête de chercher ma [ __ ]
allez montez bon on y va ça glisse ça
glisse ça glisse y avait un ascenseur
pourrais tu vas pas le prendre mais un
truc là c'est quoi voilà une photo on
voit la photo d'anna halal a dit
lunettes
on va trouver des lunettes mon gars
c'est celle de matt n'y a pas de
lunettes matt celle d'anna oh mais c'est
l'endroit où elles sont tombées [ __ ]
je n'ai pas reconnu ses ailes sont
tombés juste là hanna beth marque sur le
rocher 0202 2014
cette date où elles sont tombées dans le
trou il n'ya pas l'une des deux qui est
resté en vie quand même et qui quittait
en mode made woman vs wild non au nom
mais mais quoi
ban
obama
c'était la tête de bêtes mon gars c'est
quoi ce délai on est vraiment dans le qg
de psychopathe j'avais encore un petit
espoir qu'elle soit en mode zombie
vivante et tous mes hommes sont mortes
elles sont mortes sur le caillou va la
censure la militance est maintenant
vraiment regardèrent toi tout le temps à
l'aller tu vas dans l'ascension
maintenant tu as tes petits caprices et
mini là on se tient ce bordel allait
tuer tout le monde
pis je me tierra voilà je prends ce
levier dans ma main je le joue à la
j'aime bien le toucher un peu voilà on
s'en va waouh
j'ai peur non non ce retard et héritage
d'avant c'est le mec roland cela mon
gars c'est pourquoi je vous ferais je
vous ferais du [ __ ] c'était chaud
coups de torches counters dans la gueule
dans mes meubles non mais les taux d
elle est complètement tombé l'inconnue
revient olala le cul de ma life se coupe
les hommes voient la création
j'ai peur et puis là il a laissé sauter
au dessus des petites crapules et ses
seins à l'état on met le tout comme
samba do philippe sénéque soir à lons
tirs
voilà l'argent peut s'envoler cool le
match s'emballe et couilles
peut-être que j'aurais voilà je veux pas
d'y mettre le feu maintenant je peux
faire demi tour voilà le gril le regret
de quelqu'un au bout ces chemins se
cacher au sèche-linge et enflammé je me
cache
je me cachais ne trouvera pas il fait
aucun blessé mais qui fait aucun bruit
fin m'a fait aucun bruit fait aucun
bruit mais l'usap est morte
ok c'était la mauvaise c'est quoi ce
bordel là il fait quoi josh
alors comment il va justifier et vous
avez bien sortir bientôt
alors alors on fait quoi maintenant ça
vous a plu d'être complètement taré les
milliers et même qualité toutes ces
émotions que mes soeurs en tueur sortie
rien on est tranquille et quoi elle
non non non non non parce qu'elles sont
c'est ça c'était une vengeance pas si tu
as remarqué mon jeu mais ça fait rire
personne là allez allez allez c'est bon
d'avoir le coeur qui s'envole de temps
en temps et ils sont bien en valais tous
vos petits coeurs comme la gestion de
mes 15 et apprécier les dix spectacles
fantasmagorique
voilà c'est tout été dépassé sur cale
importunité raté
tellement appelée force marionnettistes
de toutes ces festivals en plus ces
conneries c'est super cher
ils sont ratés vous auriez dû voir jeu
set et match vous avez totalement kobe
j'y crois car ça demande même pas si
espèce de petit con feront ce qu'ils
savent pas s'ils en sais rien mais qui
est vraiment à rire c'est le synphot qui
reprennent ces médocs
non franchement les gars la vengeance
c'est le meilleur remède timor mike du
calme quoi sérieux vous allez tous le
remercier quand vous serez devenu des
des stars sur internet
pourquoi oui parce que ce petit bijou va
faire le buzz vous allez voir non
franchement on a on a que l'amour à sens
unique
on a du sens humain c'est ce que j'avais
fait un je crois qu'ils seront même pas
c'est le serveur en chine pour compter
toutes les vues que vous avez à faire
c'est gratuit
jessica hay morte [ __ ]
quoi voilà très mauvais pas elle le sait
pas jessica est morte celle de ses
paroles mais tu vas payer pour sa croix
voilà ok donc en fait y avait des gens
qui faisaient tout son petit scénario
fake là pour les faire flipper c'était
donc que de la mise en scène mais par
contient la lecture ça c'était la ferme
crise ou pas je suis plus ton pote ou
est-ce qu'on va
ou est ce que vous vendez longtemps
ferme pote quoi comme ça tu feras pas
d'autres conneries avant qu'on appelle
les figues demain matin j'ai rien fait
du tout ma gueule un [ __ ] de
meurtriers voilà ce que tu es je suis
pas mort d'un frère by pitié [ __ ] à
ixtepec moi j'ai jamais touché à jesse
[ __ ] ils vont pas le croire sermonnés
tu l'as mérité faire taire faire mal à
faire là tu es toi tais toi aller
franchement tu feras y est affirmé chris
stopper mon pote on est partenaire
historique comme si tu attends tu
arrêtes de dire ça ils savent pas qui
est un mec qui est vraiment un tueur
dans l'endroit bordel [ __ ] ils ne
savent pas je suis d un pète un câble je
sais pas quel point je suis désolé pour
tout ce qui arrive est en colère agressé
[ __ ] je sais pas je sais pas servez
geremek et de réponse quoi une housse et
être gentil avec josh et comprendre
qu'il ya un autre tueur ou l'eau tous
ses buts et joyce tu vois mal à jouer
agressif mais voilà tu pourras pas t'en
sortir comme ça [ __ ] mais ils veulent
exécuter la genre vraiment si maroc ne
tuez pas légal ne tuez pas arrêté restez
tout ce groupe mais c'est vous voulez
quoi
c'est dur à regarder ce qu'on dit plus
il a déjà dit ce genre de conneries
avant j'en ai jamais vu comme ça
tu deviens fou de joie chili et en fait
il est complètement taré suite à la mort
de ses deux tu sais ce qui s'est passé
non non c'est seulement que que j'ai un
problème bike je ne me souviens pas
avoir tiré
[ __ ] enfin ce que je veux dire c'est
que je le saurais si j'avais eu envie
que la tuer
et si noces et j'imagine qu'il doit être
super bien sûr elle est complètement
fermé d'apple
blackmont arrière
désarmé frappé josh des armées mike
désarmé miley stop stop stop stop arrête
arrête sérieusement quoi je pensais
vraiment que j'allais le tweak je sais
pas koné le cep à mike [ __ ] t'as
bonhomme arrête la prochaine fois
prévient mois avant d'accord non mais
lui non mail est protégée ça valait au
chalet pour t'assurer que tout va bien
voilà comme nature est seul et succès
fait ce que 2 buts est ok vas-y
j'aimerais trop long pas faux cas demain
matin
[ __ ] et du coup ils retournent à leur
tour ayant plus sillage son arme et il
ya même pas le passage du psy matamba
vois les gens qui y aborde cet épisode
sur un dividende bordel tout ce qui
s'est passé c'est hallucinant on sait qu
était le tueur s'était mise en scène
comme je l'avais dit ouais on est fier à
ce que personne ne sait s'il ya un 2e
mike qui lui est le vrai tueur et on
sait pas qu'il est pourquoi il fait ça
il faut il couper la tête mais on en
saura plus au prochain épisode
il n'en reste plus que 2 mai à savoir
suivie jusqu'à présent je vous dis à
très bientôt pour le prochain tu as tout
le monde par des vous bien pis qu'on me
détester gérard tout l'été la droite je
me suis voir et vu sa part passer